AND THE
HE
BENNING,
I MEAN HE'S GOT
AND LOOKING FOR
MIKE
REILLY.
WHAT THAT
PULL UP TO
ABSORB THE HIT HAS E
BACK WITH 5.5.5 BEAT
YOU AND THEY
S TO
THE HIGHER
PERCENTAGE OF
FROM TWO
GOALS DOWN TO TIE
IT.
,
SHOOTING THE PUCK
ALMOST
STANDING STILL FROM
OUTSIDE THE
TOP OF THE
REBO 25 SECONDS
TO GO.
>> MATT BENNING WITH
A GOOD REAEAOUT FIVS
PASTRNAK.
MCAVOY, AROUND
THE PERIMETER.
MARCHAND ORDER
TO OPEN UP
THE PASSES AND A
DECENT
THE PUCK GETS
PASTBRAD MARCHAND
LIGHTS THE LAMP AND.
IT SETS UP OTHER
OPTIONS.
I DON'T KNOW
7:30 INTO
THE SECOND PERIOD.
THE BRUINS HAVE
THE
TURNOVER WITH A LOT
OF GOOD LOOKS HERE
THIS
DUCHENEPOWER PLAYERE
REIL RYAN
JOHANSENAND NASHVILS
NEUTRAL
ZONE.
PASTRNAK ON THE ICE,
JAKE
DEBRUSK WITH THE OF
NINE